[Musique]
ensemble on va sauver le monde
on va sauver le monde en le saupoudrant
de créativité ou alors on va sauver le
monde
à grands coups de créativité est ce
qu'on peut sauver le monde
c'est une question que je me pose des
questions comme ça j'en ai assez souvent
j'ai une maladie un peu bénigne que
j'aime bien que je chéris j'appelle la
questionnette aiguë je me demande
souvent pourquoi pourquoi ceci pourquoi
cela sur les gestes les plus simples
exemples je rentre chez moi je prends
une bouteille d'eau je me sert à boire
debout à la bouteille est terminée le
pour l'acheter pourquoi pourquoi dans
mon cerveau j'ai une une information qui
me dit vas-y du cru d'acheter c'est pas
grave
cette bouteille d'eau c'est du plastique
le plastique on le sait ces 600 ans à
peu près pour se dégrader bon 600 ans
entre nous c'est 23-24 génération ce qui
signifie que cette bouteille d'eau si je
la garde je remet un petit peu d'eau à
l'intérieur tous les jours au moins un
litre jusqu'à ma mort avant de mourir je
vais aller voir mon notaire j'ai cédé ma
bouteille d'eau à ma famille qui a fait
la même chose pendant 22 ou 23
génération on may find me et moir
potentiellement on peut avoir réutilisé
cette bouteille d'eau environ 585 1650
fois mais moi je me dis que je peux
l'acheter
pourquoi entre parenthèses que je peux
l'acheter dans une poubelle qui est un
conteneur opaque qui me cache la
quantité de déchets que je peux faire
et puis cette bouteille elle disparaîtra
de ma vue elle partira en camion une
partie sera recyclé une partie sera
brûlé pourquoi je peux jeté cette
bouteille
pourquoi une autre pourquoi le plan
comptable le plan comptable
toutes les entreprises en france sont
basés dessus ce qu'on rentre consorts
ont le mal intérieur de cases dans le
plan comptable c'est comme ça qu'on
fonctionne et ce plan comptable
si j'emploie quelqu'un un salarié il
je le fasse rentrer dans mon plan
comptable à un endroit alors je le mets
dans une case entre parenthèse dans
cette case là il va y avoir la charge la
masse salariale du coup logiquement
comme en entreprise elle va pas bien
depuis qu'il faut que je devienne un
petit peu plus léger je regarde je vais
enlever des charges donc peut-être je ne
céderai en premier de mon salarié alors
je me dis pourquoi pourquoi est-ce qu'on
a mis le salarié dans cette case là et
est ce qu on aurait pu le mettre dans
une autre case et agir différemment en
cas de difficultés de l'entreprise et
c'est juste un plan comptable
est ce qu'à l'échelle nationale si je
change la vision du plan comptable
je ne change pas la manière dont les
entreprises vont fonctionner en cas de
difficultés
vous êtes en train de vous dire il me
parle comptabilité son sujet c'est la
créativité
kennedy je prends une somme d'argent
je la fais passer à l'intérieur d'une
entreprise qui la transmet à son
entreprise fille weather son entreprise
mère qui part dans un autre pays qui n'a
pas les mêmes lois que nous et qui
défiscalisent pour que je gagne de
l'argent et créativité comptabilité ça
marche
une dernière essayer de visualiser
simplement les voitures de vos grands
parents
c'était des belles voitures très
travaillée belle carrosserie tout vous
avez cette image ensuite imaginer la
voiture de vos parents on est sur des
modèles un petit peu plus carré puis les
voitures que nous on a électrique
beaucoup plus technologique globalement
une super évolution de la technologie
faisant la même chose avec les vêtements
les vêtements de nos grands-parents
l'époque bénie du velours côtelé les
vêtements nos parents pour certains
d'entre nous pas de df cols pelle à
tarte
les vêtements que nous avons nous
potentiellement il y en a au moins un ou
deux dans cette salle qui a un jean
encore une fois adaptation évolution
dernier exemple une salle de classe à
salles de classe de vos grands parents
et puis la salle de classe de vos
parents et puis la vôtre et celle de vos
enfants
pas d'évolution majeure un prof un
tableau des élèves
pourquoi la question que soulève chez -
c'est pourquoi est-ce qu'on n'a pas
adapté
l'apprentissage du savoir à l'évolution
de la société aussi vite qu'on a pu le
faire sur des domaines différents
pourquoi le plastique pourquoi le plan
comptable
pourquoi l'éducation l'apprentissage du
savoir
j'ai plein de questions comme ça et à
chaque fois les la réponse la même
j'en ai pas la moindre idée je sais pas
je sais pas et c'est quelque chose qui
au quotidien me tend un peu me dérange
et ce qui m'apaise c'est de me dire que
si j'ai pas la solution
peut-être que je sais comment la trouvez
ou en tout cas comment la chercher et
c'est ça que je veux partager avec vous
au quotidien une agence de communication
j'ai la chance de travailler avec une
super équipe
on propose des réponses créatives à des
problématiques avec ma soeur johan on a
monté une entreprise où on vend des
produits faits main locaux en france et
éthiques
ma petite amie flory et chanteuse et
comédienne lyrique pardon et comédienne
et chanteuse lyrique
j'ai la chance au quotidien d'être
entouré par des gens qui sont créatifs
deschamps qui stimule la créativité
je vois des gens constamment qui
inventent de leur propre cerveau
fabrique de leurs propres mains là je
peux vous dire qu'en vivant dans cet
environnement là j'ai émis une hypothèse
extrêmement simple comme un scientifique
créé c'est bon pour l'être humain
alors si j'ai cette hypothèse là je me
suis dit peut-être tu peux arriver à en
sortir des règles comme comme dans la
science et je pense que j'en ai trois
partager avec vous et c'est vrai qu'ils
sont très chouette la première tout le
monde et créatif ne laissez personne
vous dire que vous n'êtes pas créatif je
vais vous donner un argument pour le
renvoyer dans les cordes
nous sommes tous créatifs comme nous
sommes potter potentiellement tous
coureurs dans la course et les amateurs
qu'ils font pour leur bien-être qui sont
plus ou moins bien équipé il ya les
professionnels ils sont les meilleurs
les athlètes et qui s'entraîne pour le
devenir les amateurs et les
professionnels cours tous les deux parce
qu'ils ont des pieds en créativité c'est
pareil on a des professionnels les
artistes les publicitaires les
communicants mais on n'a pas assez
d'amateurs de la créativité
on n'a pas assez de gens qui font ça
pour leur propre plaisir comme on va
courir pour son propre plaisir
et pourtant l'imagination et à la
créativité
ce que les pieds sont à la course tout
le monde en a peut-être juste elle n'est
pas assez stimuler deuxième règle
créer c'est connaître prenant la cuisine
si je prends des ustensiles et des
ingrédients et que je choisis une
personne dans cette salle qui n'a aucune
connaissance culinaire je lui donne ses
ustensiles
il fabrique quelque chose et je prends
quelqu'un d'autre dans la salle pour lui
faire goûter
je vous mets au défi d'avoir envie
naturellement de goûter si je prends les
mêmes choses que je donne à quelqu'un
qui a un peu de connaissance des
ingrédients il va pouvoir faire un truc
révolutionnaire avec du kyrie d'éclat
qui
si je prends quelqu'un qui a une bonne
connaissance et des ingrédients et des
techniques
alors il va pouvoir stimuler
complètement sa créativité plus j'ai de
connaissances plus je vais pouvoir créer
plus je vais pouvoir créer plus je vais
vouloir créer et plus il va falloir que
j'augmente mes connaissances créé
stimule la curiosité créé stimule
l'apprentissage dont créer c'est
connaître troisième créer c'est relié on
pourrait faire un truc qui me fait
beaucoup rire qui pour certains d'entre
vous serez peut-être un petit peu
anxiogène
on s'enferme munci trois jours on ferme
les portes et on se dit ensemble on
réfléchit à demain plus vers demain plus
citoyen on se donnait une thématique
l'on bosse dessus
ici on est plusieurs centaines on a tous
des expériences et des savoir faire
on va se les imagine et comme étant
flottant au dessus comme des ballons ça
fait une grosse masse de savoir faire
qui est tous ici au moment où on va
fermer les portes et au moment où on va
commencer à réfléchir ensemble pour
apporter une réponse le besoin de
créativité va faire que on va émettre
des idées et il va falloir avoir des
connaissances pour répondre à ces idées
ceux qui auront les connaissances et le
savoir faire vont devoir échanger avec
ceux qui ont les idées et alors là ça va
rentrer en collision ça va brainstorm et
ça va faire des choses extraordinaires
et on va être obligé de tous
échanger pour pouvoir avancer
créer c'est relié simple une hypothèse
créer c'est bon pour les êtres humains
tout le monde est créatif plus je crée
plus je m'instruis je m'informe et 3
créer c'est relié on attend quoi
on attend quoi pour sauver le monde
j'aimerais aujourd'hui vous dire vous
appelez à une sorte de créativité
citoyenne collective tard en sorte
d'utiliser la créativité et de
l'injecter à l'intérieur de la société
comme de la grèce dans des rouages pour
faire en sorte de diminuer les
frottements dans les entreprises prenons
un thème comme la pénibilité
quitte à la bonne réponse les patrons
les employés et les actionnaires les
clients
je pense que tout le monde a la bonne
réponse et je pense qu'il faut stimuler
le groupe d'individus pour arriver à
répondre et à porter des problématiques
des réponses créatives aux
problématiques pardon dans le cas des
cours d'éducation civique
nos enfants ont des cours d'éducation
civique ils apprennent la société d'hier
est la société d'aujourd'hui injectant
de la créativité pour qu'il réfléchisse
ensemble à la société de demain je vous
laisserai avec cette image si je prends
un million d'armes à feu et que je les
donne un million de personnes
en toute logique demain je fabrique une
boucherie toutefois si aujourd'hui je
stimule la créativité d'un million de
personnes demain je pense qu'on peut
régler la faim dans le monde avec les
jardins partagés
[Applaudissements]